[Music]
welcome back developers jet here we
spent a lot of time talking about cloud
foundry but today I'm joined by sherratt
of the stackdriver team who promises to
show us how to debug our production
applications with Google stackdriver how
do you how do you sure ott can you tell
me a bit about stackdriver of course so
start over the suite of logging
monitoring and other diagnostic tools
which is primarily targeted towards
developers who are building and running
their application in the cloud it is is
designed to alert developers of problems
occurring and production and easily
diagnose the root cause of the problems
sounds great so the one good way to
experience tack driver is by actually
using the tool so why don't I just give
a quick whirlwind demo of type driver
diagnostic tool hi let's dive in all
right so let me open up an application
here that I've got running on the Google
cloud platform and let's start with
logging right so every developer of
course spend time looking at logs and
what you would see here is this is a
fairly simple straightforward log viewer
and this log viewer has of course you
can review logs as I get generated by
the application but we are added a few
more things like the ability to filter
by labor or do text search and you can
do things like log base metrics we can
export this launch to bigquery and then
you have the whole power of bigquery the
ability to slice and dice and provide
the data and in which way you want
available and all of this the export of
the query can happen in just a couple of
clicks but but one thing that we
observed was while developers and
engineers take comfort in the fact that
there is data and logs they really don't
like wallowing in it right like spending
time like you know you could you could
easily spend days looking at the laws
trying to find that one specification of
suffering in production so with that in
mind what we did was we said we can
probably do a better job of
pre-processing these logs that they come
in and so we created
error reporting and the best way to
think of better reporting is it's a
snapshot it's a single snapshot of
everything that's happening in your
application represented on one page we
take all the logs have generated scan
through each of them in near real-time
and then we intelligently group these
into different error buckets and for
each of the set of buckets we provide
some information like how often is
occurring a quick histogram of how
frequently it occurs and and and how
severe the issue is when it was first
seen when it was last seen we have the
ability to slice these error groups by
time or by versions and by the
application itself and you can of course
have this or you can click on this auto
reload that allows you to effectively
keep getting the stream of information
be updated in near real-time wow you can
click on any of these let's so let's go
ahead and click on one of these other
groups here and what you see here as you
would expect is every single instance of
that error group captured in this view
so you can drill into any of those
instances of errors within the federal
group in addition to of course showing
you the occurrences as we described
diamond a deflection last seen we give
you a more detailed histogram of where
the clock rings and we capture the stack
trace the new the most engineers are
used to is to basically look at this
this is mind-numbing view of the stack
trace yeah my my eyes glaze and blood
glacier whenever a cadet so what we try
to do is we can through every one of
these attack cases and we try to
suppress up what we believe is the most
relevant portion off that intact a quick
you can always view the whole thing by
clicking on this you all but the pass
view is meant to represent where what we
believe is the most relevant section
where we believe the problem is
occurring the route where we believe it
is the exact source of the problem so
with that with that in mind with with
all of this what you have is
developers can get a snapshot very
quickly drill into the snapshot of the
specific instance or that is occurring
and have some clues on web exact source
of the terror so if you had left it at
that you can imagine a developer coming
to the editor coding page going to the
logs and trying to understand the root
cause the common next steps we observed
is that developers would then try to
reproduce the problem that's occurring
in production on a separate dev box
another separate test box and then they
would go and insert some break points
and then inspect the application stage
try to understand where the problem
could be exactly according trying to
find the root cause of the problem and
when they believe that they found the
root cause what developers would tend to
do is to write some more code and
inserts and loves and then try to make
sure that validate that same height as
the hypothesis in production and and so
though that would require the developer
to write some code we'd apply the entire
application wait for the problem to
occur and then bingo you would see the
logs and say now I'm sure that I pawned
the root cause let me go write the lines
to go fix the problem yeah few hours
later as a few hours later some places
takes few days later sure problems could
be difficult in might occur at different
places so especially think of scenarios
where developers have rolled out only
one code to only one section of the
instances in my all because it might
have something back to the application
running in production I mean so so what
we did was we started asking ourselves
on basic questions could we capture the
application state in production when the
application was running without actually
impeding the application itself without
pausing the application without
impacting the customers and users of the
application we asked ourselves the
question whether we can insert log
statements on the fly then the
application is running without again
having to write any lines of code Wow
and and so keeping that in mind we we
start we be both the debugger to tackle
a debugger experience the best way to
think of this tax i will debugger
experience is let's take one of these
instance of applications here and here
we've got let's let's look at this we've
got what we have highlighted here and in
the relevant in the past view on the
factory is a specific file name and line
number and that that's highlighted here
is the length of a handy link if you
click on that we pop open the debugger
and what is happening right now is the
debugger is trying to take a snapshot
offered application as it's running in
real time and I think it already as we
were speaking to already took this
snapshot and and specifically when what
what what happened here is no matter
where the next time this code is
executed no matter if let's say we have
I think this application has multiple
instances run run is running on multiple
instances it doesn't matter when this
out goes Max it's going to it's going to
basically catch it a snapshot and bring
it all back into this debug view wow so
you don't even have to pick this is my
special instance I want to debug let's
write my entire application it's your
entire application it can run on one
instance can run on a hundred thousand
different instances there's no problem
at all that's incredible help we will
scale completely because without any
problem and you can also add things like
regular expressions which have to
evaluate the true so you can you could
imagine taking a snapshot when a
specific condition occurs or when a
specific expression evaluates to true
because you don't want to be taking
snapshots for every time but the code uh
cuz it's when the code occurs and the
user equals Jeff you can totally do that
Wow and and when you do that you
instantly are able to capture the
application state we can also go insert
law logs into into the into the
application logs by a simple command and
you can do that through the cloud shell
so you basically click on the cloud
shell as you used to and then we have a
very simple deeper commands handing the
radius and Andy can just go ahead and
insert loss there one thing that we also
noticed was developers really like to
look at their laws
in conjunction with the source code so
not only can you navigate your source
code which is automatically selected for
you the right version number and the
application version number and findings
already automatically collected for you
we also show you the relevant logs in
this and you can use the same things
like filtering that you're used to in
the previous view you can also look at
the various snapshot that are there cut
up but that I've taken before or you can
see the snapshot that have been taken by
other users trying to trying to debug
this application with everything that
we've done in tack driver you can share
the same you we enable deep linking door
experience so I could just copy this is
as simple as copying and pasting the URL
so i could just copy this URL and send
it over to you and when you open it you
would see the exact same view with the
exact same highlights with the same
snapshot summary so that when we decide
to debug an application together is that
simple as this copy pasting the URL and
that's something that I traditionally
have to say okay come on over to my box
I got it just right I hope I don't hit
refresh or something looks like that's
incredible it's pretty cool we like it
well seeing all these amazing features I
would love to get these integrated with
Cloud Foundry let's do it let's jump
right into it and see how we can get
this thing set up so I've gotta go
application this is running in Cloud
Foundry as I said can you show me how I
can get it set up with the debugger and
air reporting so one of the first things
to do is we first bring the wii first
your application is written in dokur so
what we want to do is bring in the
debugger agent for go for that you'll
need to modify how your app starts to
run this agent instead of running your
app directly and and so at this point
maybe we should we should do it all
right all right I'm going to pull in the
debugger agent to the same folder my
projects in and I will modify my proc
file which specifies how my application
starts instead of run any application
directly i will just run that debugger
agent instead yeah and next what you
need to do is provide some kind of
source context for the debugger so
knows which specific aggregation version
it's working with and this can be
generated with the simple gclub command
okay that sounds like an excellent job
for a continuous integration continuous
delivery sort of environment right
exactly I'll go ahead and just put it in
my deploy script for now so how does
permission work here so if you're if
you're running your application in DCP
the debugger will pick up all these
service account credentials for the
virtual machine that's running on if
you're not running on DCP you can
provide credentials to the service
account through a simple environment
variable well my Cloud Foundry is
running on gcp so I guess I'll get all
those service account credentials
automatically but for folks who are
running on other cloud providers we put
information in the example application
on how to set up credentials great so
now for the integration part will be to
pull an arrow reporting for the go
version you want to place an adult catch
in a different statement whenever you
want to catch and report Phoenix okay so
i'm going to pull in the SDK with go
vendor and then hop into my program and
import the sdk i'm just going to set up
a variable to hang on to the errors
client okay just initialize that so my
application is running with an HTTP
staff that supports middleware so he's
going to paste in an empty piece of
middleware and in there is where I'm
going to put that defer airs catch
statement so if an error occurs higher
up in my HTTP stack in the handler it'll
get caught at this point and report it
out so with that in place all I need to
do is install my middleware and that's
it
that's it so now you can use the errors
that are generated and you can start
debugging in production Wow well let's
pop up in my web app and see if there
are any bugs excellent so hop into my
application and say hello and nothing
happens so I happen to be trying this
out of production but how would I know
if a user hit this and I hadn't done
that so there are two ways you could you
could be notified or you could observe
you know that a user hits it one you can
be notified by getting a tack driver has
the ability for you to subscribe to new
errors occurring and you can get contact
to an email or if you're using one of
our mobile apps then you could get a
mobile notification as well you could of
course always keep go to the dashboard
page they had a reporting page and view
it so what if you said that the error
has occurred right now we should
probably go look at your your inbox and
see if there's a notification waiting
there ok so I'll happen to my email here
and it looks like I do have a new mail
from spectrometer ok let's check it out
so it looks like the errors occurred and
I'll just check out the details so on
this page it looks like i can see the
new air it's occurred a few times here
with different names because i've been
playing around a little bit and i can
expand this and see my request right
there that was that hello web I said I
could see it may request so I better
happen to debugger to see what what is
going on because I thought I had some
great code here apparently we've got
some issues click on that back trace and
I'm going to select my application
navigate to that specific request ok so
I know that my key and value must be
empty because I'm throwing a panic there
and so I'll just set a breakpoint above
that so I can see where data they're
getting ok so I'm getting that from
FAR's can expand bars and bars has
values in there it's got to it's got a
key and it's got a value but it why is
it empty
okay so it looks like what I'm looking
at bars I'm pulling out k and v but my
actual request sort of the form side of
it says key and value well that's
embarrassing crazy it made it through
code review but now that I've seen a
request with real user data I should be
able to fix it pretty easily Thank You
sherratt a problem and thank you all for
watching check out my application in the
description this is a cloud foundry
application written and go with the
stack driver debugger and error
reporting ready to go see if you can
find any bugs thanks for watching it's
been a great series if you've missed a
few of our videos make sure to check out
our playlist for more information about
cloud foundry and Google cloud platform
I especially recommend this video on
stack tracker if you haven't already
make sure to subscribe to the Google
cloud channel thank you